The Frozen easter egg everyone missed, secret
sacrifices, and my theory on the real reason
Olaf knows his name are just a few of the
biggest reveals in Once Upon A Snowman.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm explaining the biggest new Frozen details
we discovered in Olaf's short film on Disney
Plus.
Once Upon A Snowman is a Frozen midquel that
reveals the origins of Olaf between the time
Elsa creates him and when he meets Anna and
Kristoff.
The short film begins during "Let It Go",
and as Olaf comes to life we discover it's
actually Elsa's cape
and her iconic "the cold never bothered me
anyway" moment which sends him rolling down
the mountain setting him on the path that
eventually leads him to Anna.
"I'm alive!
Who said that?"
After pondering the nature of his existence,
Olaf wanders over to Oaken's Trading Post.
He hears Kristoff sing "Reindeer Are Better
Than People" and arrives just as Anna's leaving.
As Olaf enters, we see Oaken putting up Anna's
coronation dress for sale,
which reveals she must have been short of
cash and decided to trade her expensive royal
dress in return for the tools and carrots
Kristoff couldn't afford plus her winter attire.
This also explains a missing detail from the
original movie as to why Anna left Oaken's
wearing a purple skirt rather than the green
one she had on originally.
After entering the Trading Post, Olaf remarks
on the hidden meaning of its name:
"Wandering Oaken's?
Do you know that if you scramble up those
letters, it's an anagram for 'Naked Norwegians'?"
"Mmm?"
This fun little joke appears to be the secret
easter egg from the first Frozen movie that
Disney producer Peter Del Vecho said people
on the internet hadn't picked up on.
And if you're thinking like me that Olaf didn't
learn to read until Frozen 2.
"Okay, Olaf, you're up."
"So much easier now that I can read."
well Disney went right ahead and lampshaded
us by acknowledging this inconsistency.
"And I can't even read.
I genuinely don't know how I just did that."
At Oaken's, we also discover where Olaf's
love of summertime came from.
"Summer?"
"Mmm-hmm."
"Oh.
I don't know why, but I've always loved the
idea of summer."
When the shopkeeper puts a stereoscope on
the little snowman's face and shows him a
series of pictures.
"What is this?"
"That would be of summer."
"Summer?
It's beautiful!"
There are some cool easter eggs here and,
interestingly, many of the images Olaf sees
appear later in the main Frozen movie when
he sings "In Summer".
For example, the red and orange parasol and
the green and white striped ball are the same
ones we see in the song when Olaf is imagining
himself sunbathing on the beach.
And the slide with the bees and the purple
and yellow flowers,
as well as the dandelions in this picture
all appear during this moment from "In Summer".
♪ Bees will buzz ♪
♪ Kids will blow dandelion fuzz ♪
This image of a meadow and bandstand is from
the moment in the song where Olaf sings together
with seagulls in a tribute to Bert from Mary
Poppins.
And this red chequered blanket pops up in
the original film and again in the sequel.
"I've never identified with anything so much
in my whole life.
It's like snowmen in summer just belong together."
The short also reveals that Olaf was the original
cause of the wolf chase scene in the first
Frozen movie.
The summer sausage that Oaken gives him for
a nose attracts unwanted attention from a
pack of wolves,
and as he attempts to escape the hungry horde,
he wooshes past behind Anna and Kristoff.
That commotion seems to be why Kristoff stopped
the sled in the first movie and that caused
the wolf pack to notice him and Anna and switch
to chasing them instead of Olaf.
It's during Olaf's escape from the wolves
that he first discovers how he can disassemble
and rearrange himself at will.
"I'm falling apart.
Is this a skill or a flaw?
Skill, skill!"
There's some great physical humour in these
scenes and we can see how he learns to control
his stick hands independently of his body,
a skill that we first saw him use when he
slapped Kristoff after meeting him in the
first film.
"How does this work?
Ow!"
"Stop it, Sven.
I'm trying to focus, here."
The short also reveals Olaf's noble and selfless
side when he decides to donate his sausage
nose to a hungry wolf.
"You need this even more than I do."
Chronologically, this is the first example
of how Olaf is willing to sacrifice his own
wants and well-being for the sake of somebody
else,
as he does later for Anna in the main movie
after she's been cruelly abandoned by Hans.
"Love is putting someone else's needs before
yours."
"Olaf, you're melting."
"Some people are worth melting for."
And as a token of appreciation for Olaf's
sacrifice, the wolf gives the snowman a friendly
warm lick and a cuddle.
"That felt just like a warm hug."
This is Olaf's first experience of the warm
hugs he's so fond of telling everyone about
in the Frozen movies.
"I'm Olaf.
And I like warm hugs."
"Good afternoon.
I am Olaf, and...
Please let me finish, and I like warm hugs."
"I like warm hugs."
And as Olaf thinks about that warm hug, we
discover that he's able to hear Elsa and Anna's
voices from years ago.
"Do you wanna build a snowman?"
"Do the magic!"
These voices are from the first Frozen when
Elsa and Anna were little.
"Do you want to build a snowman?"
"Do the magic!"
My theory on the reason why Olaf can hear
these voices from before he was even alive
is because he's made of snow and ice which
are, of course, frozen water.
And as was established in Frozen 2, water
has memory, and it seems that because Olaf
is made from Elsa's ice magic he's able to
connect to her memories.
We then find out that this memory is how Olaf
discovers his name.
"I'm Olaf, and I like warm hugs."
Basically, he's recalling the name that Elsa
gave to the snowman that she and Anna built
as kids.
"Hi, I'm Olaf, and I like warm hugs."
As the short film ends we see Olaf spot Anna,
Kristoff and Sven near the frozen lake and
waterfall in the distance.
He may be nose-less at this moment, but it
shows us how he ends up wandering over to
meet them in the first movie.
And now when Anna gives him a carrot for a
nose in the main film, Olaf's reaction makes
even more sense after the events of Once Upon
A Snowman.
"Are you okay?"
"Are you kidding me?
I am wonderful!
I've always wanted a nose."
So, did you like Olaf's new origin story in
Once Upon A Snowman?
And did you spot any other interesting details
in the short film?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed these details, do leave a thumbs-up
and tap left for another Frozen video.
Or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!